あの時も「一応、おうちのために行かれたのよ」って言ったんだけど、そんなこともあんまり聞いとかないだって。
そういう時に、最初六本木に行ったのね。
その時は、その時は、日本人の人がいるので、そこに入ってらっしゃる。
一人はフェリピン人で、一人はインド人で。
日本人はみんな違うところに聞かれてね。
それって何年か決まってるの?
その時にやるんじゃない?
何年経つと終わるみたいな仕事みたいな。
もう、大変だろうと思うけど、あれじゃない?
そういう時は、一人も、別南から来た方は、青森に行かされてね。
手元はいるんだって、そこに。
その時は、その時はあんまり話してなくてね。
手元はいるんだって、そこに行くと。
そこに行くと。
どうしても、どうしても、そこに行くと。
"いつ Dockerが違う numbers potentially?"
"カラow:XXXX"
マクロ;N: Um.
" Всёозаищー"
"Russell" 一回 Byred??
"Sh Advance"
"Sexasperia"
"この前じゃなくてその前の前年目アメリカ来た時さ覚えてる あれニュージェルシーのホテルみたいなのが泊まって"
"Sexasperia" 今まだアメリカでもあのー"
"Itspo" 確かに違う業界にしたけど、あのニューヨークではね、国7人とMちゃんはまだ
エミが知ってるとこ行っていて、どこだったら全然わからないですね。
今エミちゃんはどこにいるの?
ボッソンです。まだ?
一度、あなたはどこだったか、室から見つぶり、その方に行っていて、そっちの方に行ってもいいと思って。